. Let's go next to our caller from the eight
one six area code.
Who's calling today from eight one six.
Hello, this is David from Zara.
Hey David.
What's going on?
Alright.
Um, I want to know what your opinion is.
It seems to me, I've always been of the opinion
that one of the main reasons that we have
Trump in the white house today is because
of the lack of the democratic party ability
to work together and consolidate their power.
The thing that you know, because I think it's
pretty obvious that had Hillary and Bernie
ran together in 2016 Trump would not be in
the white house.
And I don't see anyone discussing for 2020
but whenever we go through these primaries,
whoever is the top dog needs to pick the number
two as his running mate no matter what.
Because that way you cast the widest net and
get the best chance of getting Trump out of
there.
I mean,
well let's explore that David
80 and see what happens.
I think you're correct.
That had, so the question is by choosing Bernie
instead of Tim Cain in 2016 would Hillary
Clinton have gained more votes than she lost?
And I think the answer is yes.
And I think that number would have been more
than 75,000 in those three key States.
So I agree with you.
I think if Hillary went with, listen, there
were so many, so many individual differences
that would have so many factors that could
have been the difference maker in 2016 but
I think if you have Hillary, Bernie instead
of Hillary, Tim Kaine, I think Hillary wins.
Now, I do think that it's not always as simple
as the number one should pick the number two
because there are cases where the number one
and number twos contingents may not have two
and one respectively as the second choice.
So I do think that it requires looking in
a little bit more detailed than simply saying
the front runner should pick the second place
person.
But I do think in most cases, you're probably
right about that.
Now here's another question for you.
Do you think that it would also have a better
chance of casting the widest net if you have
a progressive and a centrist run together
in 2020
well, that is where you throw a monkey wrench
into this idea of going with number one and
number two, a priori, regardless of whether
they are both part of the establishment contingent
or not.
Uh, I happen to think that in this particular
election, uh, running to the middle is a mistake
no matter what I would go so far as to say
to Progressive's would be better than a progressive
and a centrist because I don't think the centrists
are going to vote for, uh, the, the Centrus
left Democrats are going to go and vote for
Donald Trump.
I think.
Sure.
There are some people who are kind of have
the brake, tear it all down to build it back
up mentality who are on the left who might
vote for Trump.
And some of them did in 2016 we saw.
But my instinct is that you were not going
to see a Bandon moment from the sort of Biden
democratic wing if you have something like
a Bernie Warren ticket.
So I think that this election is unique in
that way.
Yeah.
Well there, there also, I have no, but you
know, it has been discussed many times about
how there are, there were quite a few Obama
voters that ended up voting for Trump and
now there is a certain percentage out there
of people.
I mean, I think a lot of these people who
are, these people would have lost at life
in some way and are just desperate for change
in whatever form it takes.
Throw anything against the wall that's different
and see if it sticks
that exists.
And in fact, CNN interviewed a group of women,
some of whom claimed to have voted Obama in
2012 and then Trump in 2016 and I'll, I'll
be honest, those they didn't seem particularly
bright and they weren't making a lot of sense.
So I think you're right that sometimes just
the idea generally of change is appealing
to people.
A good, it's insights.
David.
I appreciate the call.
Thanks.
All right, take care.
Great to hear from uh, David in Missouri.